why don't we go next to Tony from the
Bay Area Tony from the Bay Area welcome
to the David Pacman show
Tony from the Bay Area you have to
accept my invitation in order to talk to
me there's Tony
okay hello hello
okay my question is about if
um Trump had the
the uh ability uh and he knew he was
going to be arrested but he had the
ability to flee like Edward Snowden to
Russia for the rest of his life to avoid
being arrested
or facing criminal charges do you think
he would take that option nope can I
tell you why
yes so Trump is a malignant narcissist
malignant narcissists believe that they
are the smartest people in the room they
believe they can talk their way into or
out of any situation there are already
articles from The New York Times And The
Guardian based on sources close to Trump
that Trump wants to be handcuffed he
wants to be walked he's seeing all of
this as a publicity tool he has no
understanding of the actual criminal
legal risk to him and believes that he
will absolutely come out on top now that
may be true but even if it was likely
that it would work out poorly for him
where it might actually make sense to
try to flee to Russia narcissists like
Trump never believe that and so Trump
would not come to believe his best move
is to flee to Russia
uh I agree with you
um and I had one more quick question if
that's okay sure
um
uh you know what I I just forgot it so
I'll let you go thank you David all
right Tony from the Bay Area
beautiful question let's go next to
matayo from DC matayo from DC welcome to
the program so great to have you on
yeah yeah it's great to be here David
can you hear me yes I can
Perfect all right so I have a pretty
quick question uh it's not political at
all uh so
as far as the memberships go I primarily
listen to your podcast on the Apple
podcast app uh and usually that's with
ads and everything and so I was
wondering if you would ever considered
charging for an ad-free version for
people who just listen to podcasts
through a particular app uh be it like
you know Amazon or apple uh just so that
we we already have it it's a member it's
an existing member benefit when you sign
up for membership there's a link in the
member section where you can generate a
custom commercial free audio podcast
link for yourself and then you just dump
it into whatever podcast player you use
it works beautifully with apple music or
iTunes or whatever it's called these
days so we're we're 10 years ahead of
you my friend
oh yeah no I know about that but uh you
know some other podcasters have like
specific membership ones that come
straight through that app uh and so
there's maybe not people like me who are
willing to double dip who already pay
for a membership but would also just
love that like sort of oh you're saying
like an iTunes only or Spotify only
premium version
exactly because I think that there are
probably a lot of people who just
primarily listen to it from that app
just purely out of convenience it's an
interesting idea I think the concern is
always spreading ourselves too thin and
then I will get flooded with emails from
people saying what's the difference
between the premium podcast through
Spotify versus the one on your website
that I can add to Spotify so let me look
into that but I I would be concerned
about spreading ourselves too thin and
just creating a customer service
nightmare
okay makes sense just wanted to ask that
question because there are you know
crazy people like me who are willing to
double dig yeah and get both uh but yeah
thanks for taking my call all right
thanks matayo from DC and by the way one
more thing YouTube is launching
podcasting in and of itself through the
YouTube music thing and everything we do
is going to be available there and I
think the functionality will will be
fantastic let's take a very quick break
we're going to go right back to Discord
and hear from more people so if you're
holding on to talk to me don't go
anywhere we're going right back in a
moment